coach pop you're unbelievable you're
unbelievable I can say I can't I can't
say a lot of stuff about you papa and
the way you cursed on me and the
language that you use to to to push me
but
I have my kids here so I'm just gonna
keep it simple
at the end of the day you threw me on a
fire at 19 years old you in five games
into my rookie year
you put me in the back in the plane you
call me and you was like you're starting
tomorrow I was like really I was like
did you talk to Timmy
because I was still thinking he didn't
like French people so I was like a
little bit scared you know
and Pop's like you'll be fine you
starting and the rest is history you're
always been the second dad to me pop
everything you did for me and my family
I appreciate everything thank you Papa I
love you